we might be drunk
we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
[Music]
hey hey patreon the boozlers we're back
good to have you with these negroni's
went down too easy too easy i know i got
to push through here i'm like i want to
just cuddle up and spoon you you want to
sure you're a weird patreon but i'm
[ __ ] down i'll should i i guess i'll
be little spoon yeah taller
i mean can we fit on this couch
yeah we could do it all right let's try
it let's give it a shot let's go oh is
this like chicken now we really go
all right let's go
come on
[Music]
oh that's a tight couch look at
[Music]
all that there we are
man this has gone off the rails in the
first 30 seconds
that's a real uh endorsement for these
yeah they're good very delicious very
good i could drink nine of them and i
got spots tonight what was i thinking
where are you at i'm at the stand and
the seller
i'm just a seller
what time i think i got two there i
don't know i think i'm there twice
all right all right well should be fun
do we have questions oh [ __ ] did you
mail it to me matt uh oh sally's uh had
one step one sip and you're on your ass
brother one sip salad lightweight yeah
that's a good that's a lightweight snail
or one sip salad what's up sally i think
that was we all had we all had a friend
like that yep we had a guy in college
sloppy steve
every time he got every time he was
[ __ ] wrecked he could not get wrecked
there's one at every party you know the
guy you go to the group and you come
back with like less yeah and you're like
oh
steve didn't make it sloppy steve slept
out of the construction site we lost him
he got pissed drunk
and just pissed on his computer whoa i
think it was a mac he pissed on his mac
because he was so drunk
tech support to like get it fixed
and they sent it back in a plastic bag
like [ __ ] yourself damn yeah that's a
hazardous waste
well yeah we can't get we're not miracle
workers you pissed on this thing what do
you want to do also we don't want to
touch it that too